Android patterns for performance
No matter how much you've improved your network code for performance,
There is still a big performance dilemma that you have not noticed,
They are bloated asset portfolios.
My name is Colt McCannless.
If you are not aggressively addressing the volume of assets you transfer to users,
You steal money and time from them.
Sending inflated assets to your users
On three big problems.
First, network speeds.
The rate of data transfer continues to be a major problem for most people around the world.
Not everyone uses 4G.
The slower the network,
The length of time required to download the data.
This brings us to the second problem of battery depletion.
The longer the duration of wireless cellular network connection,
The battery drain has increased to do this.
So the bloated files drain a lot of battery power.
Let's not forget the third problem, the cost.
Most people do not use unlimited data bundles,
Which means that every bit they transfer to their device
Of your application cost them money,
This is, in my view, a failed deal for a free application.
And unless you pay close attention
To the volume of assets you send to your users,
It will be too large.
What about the two largest sources of inflation?
Images and serial data.
For images,
Sometimes the easiest solution is to change the type of file you are using.
I mean, if you do not need transparency,
Avoid using PNG files because they do not compress as easily as their JPEG and WEBP counterparts.
If you are using JPEG or WEBP,
Remember that small changes in image quality
May create significant changes in file size.
You can greatly reduce the image quality settings
Before users begin to notice any issues.
A compromise between quality and size can be a big gain.
It is a multiplier for different types of images.
Thumbnails occupy smaller portions of the screen
It is therefore difficult to observe visual problems.
It can be managed with much lower quality than the full-screen version
Which makes it easy to observe the effects of compression.
Precision is very important for screen sizes and needs.
It is really useless to send a 4 mega pixel image to a device
And use it only as a thumbnail.
Or small-screen devices that can not display the image with that resolution;
So you need to store different quality and resolution levels for the same image on your server.
So you can optimize
So that the smallest size of the files is sent to users.
If you think the pressure will be excessive,
Remember that users pay to download your bloated files.
So shame on you.
Like images, serial data is just as complex.
Both JSON and XML are bad
Compact size hand.
I mean inflation.
Look at all those additional things stacked in these files
To make it readable by the eye,
Such as commas, spaces, quotation marks, and carriage returns.
Your users do not want to pay to send that data to their devices.
Instead, you should use binary sequencing formats.
Proto Buffs, Nano Buffs, and Flat Buffers can all be used on Android
Which can greatly reduce your data footprint
By means of small implementation tradeoffs.
By the way, do not forget that any data you serialize
Will be converted to a compressed GZIP format by the HTTP stack,
This means that the Struct-of-Arrays format should be used
To help pack fields of the same type together
So the LZ phase of the GZIP compression tool can
Better performance in discovering symbolic matches.
If you are uncertain about the amount of assets you send and the cost to your users,
You lose the Networking and Monitor tool in Android Studio
Or ARO tool from AT & T, both of which offer great information
Let you discover problems.
The discovery of problems is the essence of what we do;
So you'll lose the rest of your Android Performance Patterns.
He also joined our Google+ forum
Get great tips from people who've already resolved these issues.
So keep calm, collect your code information
Always remember that performance is important.